Seattle Washington the Emerald City has
roots in nature and high-tech is pushing
it to grow silicon branches alright guys
this way enter Michael Matt Miller looks
like buses in about two minutes
ex-microsoft now Seattle's chief
technology officer
good morning before dawn he's online are
they going to cover email archiving
pushing his digital initiatives so this
is our dashboard where the public can
come to get information on how the
government's performing performance
Seattle is his centerpiece just launched
in February open public data tells the
state of the city with metrics from nine
different city departments departments
from the police department to our
utilities home burglaries car thefts
potholes stats all here Seattle police
911 you need police fire medical coming
from here and other departments every 15
minutes so the public it's a very
real-time view of what's happening how
is the city doing at reducing crime car
Prowse how are we doing at responding
timely to yes fire 911 service matt
miller is one of a growing number of
CTOs across the u.s. from new york to
los angeles and washington d.c a sign of
height X importance in good governance
and every year we award between 300,000
and five hundred thousand dollars to
community organizations who are
dedicated to going out and offering
literacy trainings or additional access
to the Internet
I'm so excited to see the results of
your effort and more importantly I can't
wait to use them to hack my own commute
innovation by the people for the people
is another digital push we have a huge
technology community and so what a
better way to engage the public of the
part of finding that really great app
for visualization or piece of technology
that will help people make better
transportation system we're going to
work with the government data is
provided to us to provide traffic
information alerts we're gonna build
better bus depot for all of Seattle me
that commuter I can click this open I
can see what's going to happen with
Barry that I'm driving to right at the
end of the week-long events the winners
commuting apps to help people in
wheelchairs help drivers carpool and
help people choose best methods of
transport as that was really wonderful
Matt Miller believes that technology is
he to reshaping the future of Seattle
and improving the lives of the citizens
best thing about being CTO is the
ability to work with really passionate
people who care about working with the
public serving the public but also using
technology to improve our city it's what
gets me out of breath again